the moment this girl is definitely but
just in case we wanted to have a
celebration okay
Thank You mr. although he's a wonderful
teacher with been teaching at James
fruits for the last 22 years the whole
Italian teacher mr. Olver uses that many
talents as an engineer for PHP we
started seeking 26 years ago it was a
simple fire and genatech very senior
high school he came to us in 1992 and
showing the rates of legendary
mathematics teachers such as mrs. cannon
with you today and mr. canty eventually
he was given eventually Alice's can open
their new home please remove all but
eventually he was given an extension to
clocks and in 1999 mr. Olver gave James
Bruce's first first in the states of
mass expansion to exceptional results
following which many huge achieving
perfect scores and in 2010 and last year
in 2013 a applause sorry doc didn't
we'll do that again this year for stinky
little and Shelley change achieved a
double first first extension one and
thirteen extension to the result when
this year older students have always
they have standing but
he has developed a magnetic in his
students that they all remember his
students with lovely sense of humor and
I know something I don't see you but the
kid he has for them a story I said very
recently was that the doing of election
season apparently the architects or are
able to solve a problem all the group
and the Reapers are you gonna make the
problem they know what to do mr. Olver
took the problem home and came back the
next day with the solutions and hence we
have a group mr. old is intelligence and
sense of humor will only remember that
dangerous we wish you a wonderful loan
service leads and success tonight
celebrate his fabulous 22 years at least
I would just like to read an email ever
say yesterday from safety Lowell who is
commonly spending much money suspect
angry but this was written to to eating
it rolled up and I will give on the
strawberry puppy atrocities gamester
although thank you very much for taking
me it was great fun being in your club
without a doubt max Wallace and still is
my favorite subjects and said the
subject and
that's wrong that I want to look forward
to the most would cease there were four
units of mass and they took up a lot of
my time table I guess as a result I'm
awkward with his words so I hope you'll
forgive this fumbling farewell message
and repetition of adjectives to me you
really were a very inspiring teacher and
you make some great jokes to your law
Joe is particularly memorable any
general it's a good human nature that
stands out from my memory you every
teacher that you always talk to and ask
my questions too and I admit that I
might have said the loser in class found
in like 49 and I'm an ally but I really
respected you as a teacher and I feel
lucky that I can be opportuni experience
from learning from you I have no doubt
that you have helped shape the person
I've become now and my love of the
subject so thank you again for taking my
old 80s and base wishes in the future
you're grateful students safety law and
she does have a little PS and I went
really old the blue wig personal but it
says I'm enjoying family very much I
would like to keep in touch in the
future we stroller will be hearing a lot
about answers like me sir we think they
eat the best opportunity to email but we
want you to say here ever
who bills make you just thanks to us
since we started telling people that we
would like to tell the right news to
oldest tonight
and we have a lot of experiments and
students that have actually come back to
to say well I get and celebrate this
girl Miss Korea we all wish this girl of
the very base and I would now like to
isolate Assad near 11 to speak all
material come on behalf of the same
students and also presenting with the
very very special Department all around